il ya deux semaines je vous avais
proposé de me poser vos questions pour
une petite faq d'anniversaire et ouais
mais tu essaies ya un an passé et comme
à chaque fois vous avez répondu présent
c'est pour ça que je vous aime
et comme à chaque fois ça a été une
véritable torture de devoir faire le tri
parmi nos questions mais bon dans la vie
faut faire des choix
[Musique]
oui avant de commencer vous avez été
très nombreuses et nombreux à me poser
des questions auxquelles j'ai déjà
répondu dans la première faq celle de
l'année dernière
bon alors je ne juge pas c'est vrai que
c'était déjà un petit moment mais pour
pas ralentir ceux qui suivent ce que je
vous propose c'est je vous remets le
lien de la première facture dans la
description et vous irez jeter un petit
coup d'oeil après mais commençons sans
plus attendre
pourquoi avoir voulu faire détester est
ce que c'est pour également amélioré
dans le domaine scientifique ou juste
pour divertir et instruire
alors j'ai déjà répondu à la partie
pourquoi mais pour le reste j'ai envie
que les gens s'amusent rigole et qui
repartent en ayant appris une ou deux
choses voire en ayant envie d'en
apprendre un petit peu plus ailleurs si
possible voilà es-tu en couple
pourquoi n'as tu pas fait de blogs sur
la vidéo city paris je suis pas sûr que
ce genre de vlog savait vraiment sa
place sur dtc du coup peut-être qu'il
faudrait que j'ouvre une chaîne
secondaire je sais pas dites moi ce que
vous en pensez dans les commentaires
à qui appartient le squelette derrière
toi lui c'est l'ennemi vous avez le nez
me il appartient à personne c'est un
membre de la grande famille de dtc comme
nous tous avec l'aide d'associations tu
pourrais aller dans des pays du
tiers-monde faire de l'humanitaire
alors oui je pourrais et franchement si
j'ai l'opportunité je citerai pas une
seconde
quel est ton fromage préféré c'est le
gorgonzola y mascarpone
la légende raconte qu'on peut choper du
cholestérol rien qu'en le regardant
raconte-nous t'as plus grosses pontes en
milieu médical alors y'en a vraiment
beaucoup et elles sont pas toutes
racontable bon il ya bien cette nuit
qu'on travaille en réanimation que
j'avais vidé un tube de pommade entier
dans le cible d'un collègue
et pendant qu'ils étaient en train de
s'essuyer moi je rigolais comme une
baleine quand j'ai croisé le regard de
la seule patiente consciente du service
sourire qu'elle me jugeaient très forts
à travers la bi tra est ce que tu vas
changer ton intro de vidéos non
génériques alors vraiment non je ne
pense pas du tout parce que moi je les
aime beaucoup
je sais pas vous mais moi je l'aimé donc
non commentée par an ont réagi à la
carrière que toi et ton frère ont choisi
de prendre en l'occurrence youtube
nos parents sont morts est ce que tu
penses dans le futur installée dans un
vrai décor pour faire les vidéos alors
j'ai eu pas mal de questions sur ce
sujet un vrai décor non je pense pas
enfin pas tout de suite en tout cas
parce que le fonds vert ça permet quand
même pas mal de petites fantaisies
d'où vient le décor que tu utilises sur
ton fond vert ah vous voyez il fascine
valence décor est basse et cyprien qu'il
a réalisé avec ses petits doigts
gracieux à la base tu voulais être
infirmier ou tu aurais voulu être
médecin
non j'avais pensé être médecin vraiment
infirmiers ça m'allait très bien il ya
que romain derrière la caméra
ah non pas du tout derrière il ya toute
une équipe qui travaillent extrêmement
dur
non je déconne on est juste deux à quel
âge as tu fais ta première 14 à 14 mois
j'ai pris ma première cuite à 14 mois
non c'est vrai vous pouvez chercher sur
google si vous croyez quoi feras tu une
sextape avec rooney ok pour un non
bon en fait non pour moi ça te fait quoi
la barbe et les cheveux gris je m'en
bats les couilles de ta question je m'en
bats les couilles d'avoir les cheveux
gris comment se porte cyril alors
beaucoup trop bien à mon goût on va
alors le piège on en parle est
extrêmement dur
as-tu des enfants j'ai deux enfants
millio lna et vous savez quoi
eh ben ils ont tous les deux des chaînes
youtube ouais c'est toute la famille
d'ailleurs je les embrasse une raclette
[Musique]
ton groupe du moment
ultra vomit tu parce que leur dernier
album est un bijou
et le premier single de wax qui va aussi
sortir un album
têtu un ordi oui en main l'avenir
non je déconne je suis un terrien tout
ce qu'il ya de plus normal
[Musique]
merci pour toutes vos questions il y en
a eu tellement qu'on va faire une
deuxième partie à cette faq donc à très
bientôt
et d'ici là mettez vous bien et surtout
portez vous bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]